[MUSIC PLAYING]
FORREST BRAZEAL: Well, hi.
I'm Forrest Brazeal.
I'm a Cloud builder
and educator.
And I work here at Google Cloud.
Over the years, as I talk to
members of the Cloud community,
I constantly get asked versions
of the same question, which
is, how do I get into a
Cloud or DevOps engineering
role from what we might call
a traditional IT career?
So you might be a Windows
Server admin or a DBA.
You might be racking and
stacking servers or working
in a NOC, but you're
doing all that
in the context of a traditional
data center, not in the Cloud.
I actually started
my career that way
as well doing many
of the things I just
mentioned before moving into a
cloud role several years ago.
And in this video,
we're going to lay out
a path for how you can make
that transition from a legacy IT
career to a role where you
get to build on Google Cloud
Services.
So let's dive right in.
OK.
The first question you're going
to want to ask yourself is why.
What's the point of choosing a
Cloud role when maybe I already
have a career that's going fine.
I'm in a good groove.
And an easy answer might
be the Cloud market
is very hot right now.
Take a look at
these numbers here.
Look at these salaries
associated with Google Cloud
certifications.
This data is from
Global Knowledge.
And to be clear, I
didn't cherry pick this.
Those top two numbers you see
there for Google Cloud certs,
those aren't just the top two
paying Google Cloud certs.
They aren't just the top
two paying cloud certs
in the world.
Those are the top two certs
anywhere in IT as of 2021.
Just to be very clear, you know
and I know that certifications
are not the whole story here.
It's very difficult to get
hired into a cloud role
unless you can show some
hands-on experience working
with cloud, even
if you've already
got experience working
in a traditional IT role.
So how are you going
to get that experience?
And this is kind of a
unique problem for you,
because you may not be able
to just go back to square one
and start again with schooling
or something like that.
You've already got a career.
Maybe you've got a family.
You can't take two steps back
to take one step forward.
You've got to find a path
to this cloud role that's
going to enable you to augment
your skills without starting
over.
So here's what I
recommend that you do.
We're going to cover three steps
to your cloud career coming out
of traditional IT.
We might call them the
three IT cloud commandments.
The first one is that
you need to exploit
your unfair advantage.
What do I mean by this?
You'll hear this term used
a lot in the startup world
where founders talk about
finding the one thing they
do better than anybody else
and just really doubling down
on that.
Well, if you're
watching this video,
your unfair advantage may
be that you're already
employed in some form of tech.
IT is in your blood a
little bit as you were.
And that's going to give
you a tremendous advantage
relative to other people
who are trying to break
into cloud for the first time.
But you've got to
access this advantage.
And that's going to likely
look taking advantage
of the existing
opportunities you
have to get close to cloud
in your professional context.
Cloud builds on fundamentals
that have been around
for a long time--
compute, networking, storage,
all forms of access control.
These are things that you
understand that you've
got some context with.
So why not figure out how to
cloudify those existing skills,
how to turn those skills into
cloud versions of themselves?
There's three steps
to doing this.
The first step is simply
to build the thing
that you already know.
So let's say that you're a SQL
Server DBA, like I used to be.
OK.
Well, let's see if
you can stand up
a SQL Server in Google Cloud.
You can use the
console for this.
You can point and click around.
The point is just to transfer
your knowledge of standing up
a SQL Server on the old data
center in the virtual machine
to standing it up
in Google Cloud.
Second step.
Once you've done that, go ahead
and automate that same process.
So now instead of pointing
and clicking, instead of
using click ops, you're going
to use some form of automation.
You're going to use
something like Terraform
to automate the standing up
of that underlying server.
You're going to use some
scripting or automation
to make sure that that
SQL Server is initialized
the same way every time.
You're going to use some
form of source control
to make sure that you keep
track of all that configuration.
And you're going to use some
sort of a CI/CD pipeline,
we assume, to make sure
that that code gets
from your laptop into
the cloud the same way
every time without you
touching it in between.
And then once you've
done that, the third step
is to try to reproduce the
same idea using Managed Cloud
Services.
So instead of SQL Server,
you might say, hey,
I wonder if I could achieve the
same results using Google Cloud
SQL or maybe Google
Cloud Spanner.
Give it a try.
It's going to expand the
circle of what you already
know to encompass the cloud.
Now, on the other hand, you
may see things happening
in your company that are
cloud related that you are not
part of and don't feel
like you have the ability
to access right now.
There might be a cloud
engineering department
over there across the hall.
And you see what they're doing.
And it looks really
cool, but it's just not
related to your
current job at all.
In that case, I would recommend
go talk to those people.
See if you can sit down
and have lunch with them.
Ask to pick their brain.
Ask for some mentorship.
Buy them coffee.
Max out your access
to colleagues who
do what you would like to do.
That's part of your unfair
advantage right now is
having access to those
people and to their problems.
Who knows?
Worst case, you're going to
learn a lot about what they do.
You're going to get great
advice from them on where you
need to focus your skilling up.
Best case, they might have an
internal role opening up soon
that you are top of mind for.
Just leverage the heck
out of those connections.
Only good things
are going to happen.
But-- and this is important--
if those opportunities aren't
coming to you
naturally, you don't
need to sit around
forever and wait for them.
Ultimately, it's
not your team that's
responsible for the
trajectory of your career.
It's not your employer.
It is you who's
responsible for it.
So if the cloud opportunities
are not coming to you,
you need to go out and get them.
And that brings us to our
second IT to Cloud commandment.
And the second commandment
is to boost targeted skills.
And I'm being very deliberate
in saying it that way because,
again, as we've
said, you may not
have time to kind of
burn the house down
and start from square one
with going back to school
and building up every
skill from scratch.
You've got to figure
out where your gaps are.
And you've got to
make very intentional
targeted improvements
to those gaps.
There are four areas that
you can dive into here.
And the first is you
have to learn to code.
There's a reason that people who
come from software development
backgrounds tend to find it
much easier to get in the Cloud
than people who come from
traditional IT backgrounds.
And that is because code is
a non-negotiable if you want
to become a cloud engineer.
You're not able to just point
and click or use the GUI
to manage things anymore.
You have to be able
to automate if you're
going to keep up with the
massive scale of a cloud
environment.
So if you don't have a cloud--
if you don't have a language
you already know, try Python.
It's pretty ubiquitous
in cloud environments.
But code is the barrier.
And code is the bridge to
a cloud engineering role.
You don't necessarily have
to be an elite code person.
You don't have to be
crunching algorithms.
That's not going to come up
a lot in a cloud interview.
But you do need to be able
to perform basic automation
and data manipulation tasks that
do come up every day in a cloud
role.
Learn to code.
Second thing.
Learn the basics of
Linux and networking.
And this may be
something that feels
more core to what you've been
doing in IT and that's great.
But you will need to
remember the Linux file
system, basic Linux commands.
You'll want to make sure you
understand the fundamentals
of containerization.
And of course, you'll want to
the core networking concepts
like the IP Protocol and
all the other protocols
that layer on top of it, DNS,
subnets, all that good stuff.
Again, some of this may
be more familiar to you.
You've touched it before.
There's lots of
courses and videos
out there you can
use as a refresher.
But these are not going
away in the cloud.
They're only becoming
more important
because so many systems
are built on top of them.
And you will want to make sure
that you're fresh on those
when you go into an interview.
So code, Linux, and networking.
Third thing.
If you want to get a cloud
job, believe it or not,
you actually should
know a little bit
about the cloud itself.
In this video, we're
talking about Google Cloud.
So how are you going to
learn about Google Cloud?
I recommend Google
Cloud Skills Boost.
It's Google's own platform for
training you on Google Cloud.
And you can check out the
infrastructure modernization
track there.
It's got a nice combination
of hands-on learning
and certification prep.
Yeah.
We talked about how
certifications maybe
have some limitations, but I
do think it's important for you
to have a Google
Cloud certification
if you're trying to transition
into a Google Cloud role.
And given where you
are in your career,
I would recommend you go
after a professional level
certification like the Google
Cloud Professional Architect.
It's going to be
difficult, but it's
going to signal that
you're serious, that you're
a pro on this subject.
And given where you are,
I think that's going
to be necessary for you.
Code.
Linux and networking.
Go deep on Google Cloud.
And then finally,
you're going to want
to have some familiarity
with open source tooling.
Whatever cloud provider
you go to work on,
there's going to be
certain tools that
pop up in almost every shop.
Doing automation?
I've already said it.
Terraform is probably going
to be involved in some way.
Working with containers?
Kubernetes is probably
going to be on the table.
These are open source.
They travel.
They're portable between clouds.
Take some time to learn those.
Use something like
Kubernetes the Hard Way
from Kelsey Hightower.
Figure out what Kubernetes
is, how it works,
what problems it's
good for solving.
With Terraform, learn how to
deploy some cloud services.
And this brings us to a piece of
advice that should tie together
all four of the areas
I just mentioned,
which is before you
start interviewing,
you'll want to build a
couple of hands-on projects.
What do I mean by that?
Take these cloud
skills you've learned
and actually create something
that's real, that's live,
that's out there in the world,
that you can use as a story
during an interview.
I'm very serious about this.
For a couple of years,
I've been running
a community initiative called
the Cloud Resume Challenge.
It's free.
You can do it on Google Cloud.
And it'll get you up close and
personal with almost everything
I just mentioned.
Give you something that you
can talk about in an interview.
You can check that out at
Cloudresumechallenge.dev.
OK.
So let's say you've exploited
your unfair advantage as
much as you can.
You found your skills gaps.
You've plugged them
as much as you can.
And now here you
are in interviews.
And you're still not getting
traction on that cloud engineer
or cloud architect
role that you wanted.
Don't worry.
This brings us to
the third of our IT
to Cloud commandments,
which is you may need
to take a stepping stone role,
not moving backward but taking
an intermediate step before you
get to your end destination.
And there's a lot
of different roles
you can take that'll move
you closer to the cloud.
I'm not going to be exhaustive
here on what I mention,
but I'm going to list
several that I've seen
be helpful to a lot of people.
Number one-- and this is the
first thing I would try--
you can look for an IT admin
role that has a little bit more
of a hybrid aspect to it.
So while cloud
qualifications are not a must
in order for you
to get hired, you
know when you look at
that company's environment
that they have some
stuff on-premises
and they have some
stuff in the cloud.
And either they're going to be
moving the on-premises stuff
to the cloud or they're going to
have both of these environments
around for a while.
And so even though
you're probably
getting hired based on your
traditional qualifications,
you know that you're
probably going
to be migrating
to the cloud right
along with these workloads.
So you've got some
cloud advancement,
some cloud skilling
up that's built
into your professional role.
We talked about
wanting to get that
with exploiting your unfair
advantage internally,
but this would be
looking for a company
where you can do that
if you can't do it
where you are right now.
So look into that
hybrid IT admin role.
Second thing you might
want to check out,
you might look into what we
might call a cloud engineering
adjacent role.
So there's a lot of companies--
Google does this.
A lot of their
partners do this that
have these roles called
Technical Account Manager
or TAM, Technical
Program Manager or TPM.
These are roles that are not
technically engineering roles,
but they are very technical.
A lot of times, deep
traditional IT experience
is a big plus when you're
getting hired into these roles.
And you'll be hands-on
with customers.
You'll be hands-on with
Google Cloud solutions day in
and day out.
These can be a great way
for you to transition
into a true cloud
engineering role over time.
Third thing-- and this
might be more interesting
if you're a little
earlier in your career,
would be to become
a cloud support
engineer at Google Cloud or
another of the major cloud
providers.
This is kind of like the
help desk of the Cloud.
But instead of turning
people's laptops on and off,
you'll be helping
them troubleshoot
cloud administration issues.
Great way to get up close and
personal with a huge variety
of cloud tasks.
You'll get very hands-on
and it will set you up
for more advanced
roles in the future.
And then finally-- and
this may surprise you--
there actually can be a
lot of value to becoming
a technical trainer.
Believe it or not,
teaching someone something
is still one of the best
ways to learn the thing.
And I've seen a lot of
people, especially in my time
working at A Cloud
Guru and Pluralsight,
make this fluid career
transition back and forth
between training and being
a hands on cloud engineer.
It actually does work.
It's interesting to try.
Now remember,
there's no law saying
that if you do take one of
these intermediate positions
that you are stuck in it
for three to four years.
I mean, this could be
like a three to six
month slingshot
opportunity for you
where you build some
experience and then you're
ready to boomerang onto that
cloud engineering opportunity
as soon as it comes open.
Remember what we said.
The cloud market is very hot.
And as soon as you
start racking up
this professional experience,
those inbound LinkedIn
connections are going
to start rolling in.
That's just reality.
In conclusion, big finish.
Take an incremental
path to the cloud.
Don't go backwards.
Instead, maximize your current
advantage wherever you can.
Take advantage of the
people that you're
close to that understand cloud.
Take advantage of your
current professional work
and cloudify it
wherever you can.
When that doesn't
go far enough, try
to boost targeted
skills to close the gaps
and make yourself more
attractive to employers.
That includes certification.
That includes hands-on
projects, probably
the most important thing we've
touched on in this video.
And then finally, if that's
not quite getting you
to a true cloud
engineering role,
consider one of these hybrid
or stepping stone roles
that will get you
where you want to be
without taking you backwards.
Thank you so much for taking
the time to listen today.
I hope you'll like
and subscribe.
And make sure to
join us next time
as we bring you more advice
on cracking the Google Cloud
career.